dans ce hangar du matériel pour venir en
aide à plus de 5000 personnes
la croix rouge française se tient prête
à envoyer ses kits de première nécessité
dans les zones dévastées par l'ouragan
rma ici nous avons des kits habits alors
ce kit est composé de certaines nombre
de petits et moyens matériels on va
trouver des fous qu'on va trouver des
placements offshore ou s'y met ou
bourdages tout ça qui est accompagné de
deux matchs de quatre mètres quand
simule la croix-rouge envoie également
des purificateurs d'eau et des kits de
nettoyage pour faire face aux importants
dégâts causés par les catastrophes
naturelles sont tous deux d'accord de
nettoyage d'une est proche
le masque a poussé la plate-forme
d'intervention régionale amériques
caraïbes peut apporter une aide
logistique dans toute la région
ce matériel peut être acheminée
rapidement vers les zones sinistrées
moins de 48 heures après le passage de
l'ouragan rma pour les pays où ce matin
et la faute d'abord qu'il y ait une
évaluation après la catastrophe des
besoins est ici
à fonction des besoins de la demande que
nous mettons à la disposition ce que
nous avons le disponible parce que c'est
cet entrepôt est ici basé ici à moitié
nous avons deux autres qu une voix de
lou une régulière ou compléter si les
gens cherchaient de l'apatite et la
délégation territoriale de la
croix-rouge cherche également du renfort
sur le terrain des bénévoles formés sont
d'ores et déjà sollicité pour mettre en
place les hébergements d'urgence